Jeff:
Do you think we'll make it?
Not without my team.
Finch:
We do this together.
♪♪
(Warning Klaxons blare)
Finch:
It all happened so fast.
(Warning Klaxons blare)
Finch:
There was a solar flare.
(Warning Klaxons blare)
Finch:
Goodbye crops and food, goodbye
everything.
(Warning Klaxons blare)
♪♪
Finch:
So I... hid...
(Deep breath)
(Door shut)
...frightened and so alone.
♪♪
Finch:
And I found you.
♪♪
(Dog whimpering)
Well, what should we have?
Get your elbows off the table.
Alright, you're next.
(Dog whimpering)
♪♪
Finch:
You see, I'm developing
something interesting.
(Electrical click)
A giant leap of faith.
(Robot beeping)
(Sight of joy)
Now if you can speak,
tell me something... about you.
beep, beep, beep
Robots must protect dog.
(Laughing)
(Dog whimpering)
(Alarm "warning")
Finch:
We don't go before that storm
hits, we'll die.
Finch:
All of us.
As soon as you can walk, we're
leaving.
(Barking)
Jeff:
One, two, one, two.
(Dog barking)
One...
That's falling.
Jeff:
One, two,
(Dog whimpering)
♪♪
Finch:
Head west, over the mountains.
♪♪
Jeff:
Would you like me to drive?
(Barking)
Don't oversteer.
Finch:
That's oversteering!
Jeff:
Sorry.
Ease your foot up just a hair.
Perfect.
(Horn honking)
Huh.
(Dog barking)
Hey, what's all the fuss?
I learned to talk dog.
I don't think it likes me.
(Barking)
(Wind sound)
Come and see this.
(Barking)
(Wind sound)
Finch:
Tie the RV down.
(Wind sound)
Hang on to something,
(Crashing sounds)
Finch:
Ooh!
♪♪
Finch:
We should be safe once we get
into the mountains.
But things will happen.
♪♪
Finch:
Like 150 degree heat.
UV radiation.
♪♪
And people...
Finch:
...hiding in the shadows.
Go now!
(Barking)
♪♪
Jeff:
Do you think we'll make it?
Finch:
Not without my team.
What we do, we do together.
♪♪
Jeff:
I believe in you, Finch.